down all right hey rocky may have gotten
the barbecue but look what i got right
here we're talking sweets for your
sweetheart and for that we brought in
the executive pastry chef for the red
rock casino gerard fabiani thank you so
much for being here well thank you so
much for having me so love is in the air
and to celebrate this year valentine
green valley ranch bake shop and a
redwood bake shop i put on some
beautiful desserts and some very
specific items beautiful display and
this is a big time of year right
absolutely so
we wanted to make special of course once
uh once again so we made some breakable
hearts we have some new teddy bears so
we have a range of desserts and i think
it's such a fantastic idea for your
companion or your lover to to celebrate
with your valentine i love it and these
teddy bears are no ordinary teddy bears
you get to do something fun with each
other absolutely are we going to play
with this one yes okay so tell us what
this is what we do here so we're going
to like glue the top of it okay
and then i am going to let you break
that so as you see they are filled with
uh leaves did you see that guys which
camera you want down three
so there we go
yes oh it's one sorry okay so boom we're
going to put that on top of that
absolutely
we're going to glue a little bit over
here okay so it doesn't move
just like that okay and then i'm going
to let you do this with a mallet all
right just to have fun this segment got
better all right absolutely all right
just slam it you just slam it okay and
then you can eat one all right
there you go fantastic and this is
edible too this is edible oh that's
fantastic this is one of many i mean
this is a beautiful spread here thank
you so much what are some of your
favorites well i i would say that i
really like the the cheesecake you know
the separation of the red the red glaze
and the white glaze with gold it really
really makes a an effect on it and of
course we have like an offering of a
stacked cookie dough with some whipped
cream and some fruits shaped as a heart
so
just beautiful on top of being delicious
how did we end up lucky enough to have
you here in the states you grew up in
france i did yes i am originally from
france from the south of france and how
did you end up in las vegas well it is a
company who decided to uh send me in the
u.s and uh first it was in florida and
now i'm in las vegas well we are
thrilled you're here because we get to
enjoy your work it is beautiful so thank
you thank you so much thanks so much for
being here and uh i hope people take
advantage of all the opportunities you
have at the red rock as well as so they
can order this online the breakable
heart and the teddy bear so the
breakable heart goes for 75
and the teddy bear for i'm sorry for 85
and then the teddy bear 75.
this one is at the green valley ranch
a showcase at lucky penny we have two
locations of course and this one because
it's a little bit smaller it goes for
25. oh all of it beautiful thank you so
much thank you so much i really really
appreciate it rocky